[Music]
we'll see the bluesman of course is the
blues woman is someone who begins with
the catastrophic see the Blues
autobiographical chronicle of personal
catastrophe expressed lyrically so the
lyrical responds to the monstrous like
the first sentence of Kafka's of
metamorphosis
Gregor Samson grows up uneasy
I mean wakes up from an uneasy dream
finds himself transformed in bed to our
huge valve airman that's catastrophic
its catastrophic situation the poor
people's catastrophic black people had
slavery Jim Crow Jane crow catastrophic
what was the response what it create a
black al-qaeda
it wasn't counter terroristic in the
face of slavery Frederick Douglass said
what with a smile and wounds we want
freedom for everybody we don't want to
enslave others just because we're
enslaved Jim Crow we have no rights and
liberties we're civically dead we want
rights and liberties for everybody we
don't want to Jim Crow somebody else the
Blues responds to the catastrophic with
compassion without drinking from the cup
of bitterness not with revenge but was
just this that's the best of the Blues
you see and so the Blues people in
America have been the leaven in the
Democratic loaf because black people
could have chosen counter terroristic
tactics when they were lynched over and
over and over again they said no we're
not gonna go out and Lynch white folk we
would rather be defeated for the moment
with integrity then win and be a
gangster like them that's a blue
Sensibility it's a blue sensibility let
that love inside of you be expressed
even though it's hard for it to be
translated into love war justice on the
ground that's a great lesson in this age
of terrorism and in the age of recession
you see and so some blues men like
myself in the life of the mind and jazz
men in the world of ideas says I want to
tell the truth the condition of truth to
allow suffering to speak and as a
Christian I believe in unconditional
love that's why I love brother Larry
Summers I want him to have more joy in
his life it's hard
have a lot of arrogance and have a lot
of joy at the same time I wanted to have
more joy
less arrogance but unconditional love
was always tied to justice justice is
love own leg spilling over to the public
sphere
no being is just a different
institutional array of sources of what a
blue since been I keep in mind by blues
sensibility what I have in part and mine
is a tragic comics view in which
compassion responds to catastrophe see
in that sense Walter Benjamin is a blues
man and the thesis on philosophy of
history and the ninth instance you see
the history is catastrophe college of
records upon records that pile of debris
but the response is messianic is weak
but the Messianic is what to keep alive
the memory of those who struggle before
based on their compassion for the poor
based on their attempt to resist the
powers that be so that by blues I don't
mean just a particular art form it's
really a way of life that that art form
helped popularize so even in the media
and in the context of the media you can
be a blues person without even being
able to sing but you can have a tragic
comic sensibility that keeps track of
the catastrophes all around us it could
be personal catastrophe art break it
could be shipwreck it of mine
intellectual catastrophe could be social
catastrophe crisis it could be Wall
Street catastrophe for the well-to-do
and others and then the catastrophe
that's always in place for the poor
always at work with housing education
unemployment and so
sixties sensibilities where people had a
love for poor people it wasn't a
condescension of helping out
we had a love for poor people of poor
people's music like Curtis Mayfield we
love poor people's music the genius that
came out of the ghettos the Donny
Hathaway's and others you see and it was
also true the other side the brother
Bert spring stings the the white blues
men out of work in classes New Jersey
and they weren't geniuses because in
working class but they were
extraordinarily ordinary people who
happen to be geniuses in their genres
and that was the sly stones everyday
people who we loved everybody the Stars
Sly Stone
that's what shaped and molded me and I
am old school to the core unapologetic
Motown Stax Philly international sound
Curtis Mayfield
Al Green Aretha WB the boys Leroy Joe's
transferring into Baraka but especially
allowing cuz I've has a Christian I
start with black people in terms of my
love but it spills over to white
brothers and sisters brown red yellow
across the board so I believe it spilled
over love and since justice is what love
looks like in public you can't talk
about loving folk if you're not fighting
for justice especially beginning with
the least of these
[Music]